googoo gaga hi I'm raylene I'm Ricardo I
am the hall I'm Christina and we're
gonna be trying baby food today I'm
pretty excited how you feel looking kind
of excited
I'm imagine like applesauce awesome like
gravy now for some reason no all right I
want to try the fruity ones cuz I feel
like that can't be that bad right like
squishy fruit is just fruit but squishy
burger it consumes you throw an animal
into baby food like that kind of
sketches me out
what did meat does not sound advertising
you're saying you don't like the flavor
I kind of I think I should so like pull
opposites and see how this works out if
I like to when I was a baby I might like
it now we'll see that's that's true
that's kind of I don't have to chew it
baby food no well would you get anyways
okay it's a very Apple sounds like your
son's gonna be really good yeah or as
good as baby food can get if you don't
read it it looks like pudding
Oh baby proof yeah for sure
textures really weird liquid here like
watery big scoops excuse we're not we're
not losers okay
mmm-hmm Cheers oh that's really good oh
wow it's refreshing give everybody you
know when you give babies food in there
like this is the kind of energy that has
like yeah totally understand where
they're coming from they've had a baby I
would definitely feed him this but I'd
probably eat it myself so doing really
good
honestly I have kids I'm probably like
steal about Frank yeah they don't know
any better I'll try it
I'm a DJ what happens it just tastes
like apple sauce yeah very easy this is
not that bad
I'm I'm here for this like the off-brand
but the one that tastes like almost
exactly the same that's that's what our
farmers grow their best for baby
anything for baby TM is yeah I don't
know if they're gonna give us after this
what this is probably nice
if we're here yeah wait ham and gravy
this looks literally like deshaun
mustard oh it smells like the railing at
the Santa Monica Pier we're like
everyone cuts their fish no we got I'm
gonna like cry we feel it was so like
grainy and gelatinous there's no way on
earth I would ever eat this thing I need
a doctor or the game for those gaming
games I would eat it I'm gonna get my
kids is next
thank you so this is sweet potato like
it looks good like it looks like naked
juice you know you gotta get the taste
of the chicken out of my mouth honestly
so let's get into please of my finger
should I look at or should I wait try
together
this is look a lot more liquidy yeah it
secretly cheers yeah that's a great
point
I like it I really don't like that at
all
no not gonna lie I thought you just like
everything even airplane wouldn't work
for this you're believing you didn't
like I think I would actually start
before I ate this this one's definitely
like in the middle yeah a chicken is
like in the ducts of hell it's gross
it's the worst one it's worst one yeah
this is your this is what isn't because
one hammy gravy was too and then fruit
was 9
it's a good thing we save this for like
the end this is the Apple blueberry you
eat this all day every day
I probably definitely yeah it's pretty
good it's so good ham and gravy kind of
cancelled but the nutrition facts
say otherwise or gains phenomenon yeah
chicken oh it's horrible that's like a
negative like 100 I think that's the
worst thing I've ever eaten in my entire
life
no the the puss wheat potato sweet
potato was the absolute worst thing I've
ever tried an entirely I have to
disagree everything else can go but the
applesauce this day I would definitely
try baby food again no yeah I would
definitely try like the fruit flavored
ones both the savory ands or not not as
I'm good I can't hear anything because
they don't have teeth oh yeah
[Music]
you